As we've said, health informatics
serves healthcare delivery,
the translation of medical knowledge
into the care of actual patients.
Its key components are electronic
medical records, which are created and
used by licensed professionals, patient
generated personal health records.
And a technology called
Health Information Exchange
that can be used to share information
among providers and patients
in order to aggregate information
to create a more comprehensive and
holistic electronic health record,
to manage patient populations and
the public health at large and
to support research of various kinds.
Accomplishing this data exchange demands
technologies to assure privacy and
security of health data
as required by law.
And other technologies
to define standards so
that data from diverse sources
can be meaningfully combined.